In late 2017, Netflix themselves released a surprising statistic...
...that more than 8.4 million of their subscribers have 'binge-raced',...
...which is where they watch an entire season of a show within 24 hours of its release.
Their figures show that the countries with the most number of subscribers doing this...
...are the US, Canada, and Denmark.
Watching shows or movies is an increasingly enjoyable experience,...
...and there's a reason for that.
Taking part in fun activities triggers the release of dopamine in the brain,...
...which rewards you with pleasure for doing the activity,...
...and encourages the mind to continue.
In fact, so much dopamine can be released when watching your favorite show...
...that you experience a high,...
...and even an addiction-like craving for this neurotransmitter.
This process is the same as what the brain goes through with addiction to drugs,...
...since your body doesn't distinguish...
...between the different causes of pleasurable experiences.